hello everyone in this video we'll
discuss disaster recovery for gke
available on Google Cloud
the content creators for this video are
tanvi Desai and the kriti Gupta who are
technical account managers for Google
Cloud
they have curated the information for
you to have a deeper understanding of
how to protect your gke workloads in
Google Cloud
let's talk about why it is important to
discuss disaster recovery and what it
looks like for gke
we will review how to enable backup for
gke and see how some of our customers
are finding this feature useful
finally we will share some resources for
you to follow up with
so let's Dive Right In why do you need
to plan for Disaster Recovery
disasters come in forms that can affect
your critical workloads and business
it could be in the form of a natural
disaster like flooding fires or
earthquakes
it could be a technological disaster
such as power outages cyber attacks and
data breaches
or the disaster recovery scenarios can
include human-caused disasters such as
explosions terrorist attacks or huge
production errors
disasters can occur anytime and in any
form they are often unavoidable the key
is to always be prepared with a recovery
plan
no matter what type of disaster strikes
a disaster recovery plan can help you
protect your data restore your it
infrastructure and recover your business
operations
now more than ever significant
infrastructure downtime can have a
devastating impact on an Enterprise
business
as shown here analysts have estimated
the average cost of data center outages
around nine thousand dollars a minute
that's 13 million dollars per day a
potentially huge impact and the impact
isn't just monetary in many cases the
impact to a business's reputation can be
even more catastrophic and take longer
to recover from if ever
as a result Enterprises are increasingly
mandating the implementation of robust
backup and Disaster Recovery Solutions
to provide them with insurance against
the unexpected
this can help you to avoid costly
downtime lost productivity and even
business failure
by implementing backup and Disaster
Recovery in Google Cloud you can help to
protect your critical cloud workflows
from a variety of threats
you can ensure that your business
continues to operate even in the event
of a disaster this can give you peace of
mind and help you to focus on running
your business
every workload is unique and Google
Cloud offers a variety of protection
strategies to choose from depending on
your business and industry
it enables on-demand resource allocation
for unprepared events to minimize the
cost of support and help you focus on
backing up your critical workloads
so how do you design strategies for
Disaster Recovery
think about what are the most important
things your organization does
these are the functions that you need to
make sure can be recovered quickly in
the event of a disaster
recovery time objective RTO is the goal
your organization sets for the maximum
length of time it should take to restore
normal operations following an outage or
data loss
recovery Point objective RPO is your
goal for the maximum amount of data the
organization can tolerate losing you
will need to determine how much data you
need to protect and how quickly you need
to be able to recover when the disaster
happens
the lower the RTO and RPO requirements
are the cost of Disaster Recovery gets
higher
what are the types of disasters that are
most likely to impact your organization
once you know what risks you face you
can start to develop strategies to
mitigate them
your recovery plan should include steps
for recovering each of your critical
business functions it should also
include a timeline for recovery and a
budget
it's important to review your recovery
plan regularly run tabletop exercises
and simulate disaster scenarios to make
sure your Disaster Recovery plan is
effective and up to date
consider the additional costs and
capacity needed for running these
exercises
make sure the key stakeholders in your
organization know their role and
understand your Disaster Recovery plan
while planning for Disaster Recovery be
flexible no two disasters are the same
so your recovery plan should be flexible
enough to adapt to different situations
get help from experts if you don't have
the expertise in-house to develop a
disaster recovery plan consider working
with Google Cloud experts
let's talk about Google Cloud's
high-level approach on disaster recovery
on gke by discussing its key components
gke node Auto Repair repairs unhealthy
nodes in a gke cluster when enabled gke
will periodically check the health of
each node in the cluster if a node fails
consecutive health checks over an
extended time period gke will initiate a
repair process for that node
the repair process for an unhealthy node
may involve one or more of the following
steps
gke will start draining the node by
stopping scheduling new pods on the Node
it will then replace the node and
migrate pods from the unhealthy node to
the new node lastly gke will scale the
cluster by creating additional nodes in
the cluster to compensate for the loss
of the unhealthy node this will keep
your cluster healthy reduces manual
intervention improves availability and
reduces costs
gke allows you to specify a liveness
check that will run periodically to
ensure your pod is running successfully
this mechanism ensures that a container
is running and healthy when you
configure liveness probe in your pod
spec kubelet checks the health of the
Pod every 5 seconds if the Pod fails the
liveness probe three times in a row it
will be restarted
gke safeguards your storage availability
by mapping to persistent disks through
persistent volume abstraction
persistent volumes are a kubernetes
resource that provides a way to store
data that persists even if the pods that
use the data are deleted they are backed
by physical storage such as Google
compute engine persistent disks
this can be useful for storing data that
needs to be available even if a pod
fails or is restarted
the multi-cluster Gateway supports
internal and external load balancing
weight-based traffic splitting traffic
capacity based load balancing and
traffic mirroring between your clusters
multi-cluster Ingress lets you configure
shared load balancing of resources
across multiple gke clusters in
different regions
it improves application availability
reduces operational complexity and
increases scalability and provides a
single entry point for users to access
applications and manages traffic across
multiple clusters
spreading the kubernetes control plane
and its nodes across different zones or
regions for the workloads is very
important to achieve High availability
one option is choosing to deploy your
kubernetes workload in a regional or a
zonal cluster
second within zonal gke offers two types
of node pools single zone and
multi-zonal
single zone clusters have one control
plane machine and worker nodes in the
same Zone
multi-zonal clusters are similar to
zonal clusters but they span nodes
across multiple zones
a regional or multi-zonal cluster will
provide a highly available cluster
Regional clusters are better suited for
high availability as they have multiple
control planes across multiple compute
zones in a region while zonal clusters
have one control plane in a single
compute Zone
however if cost is a factor or your
workload is not as critical a
multi-zonal cluster could be a better
choice
in Regional clusters the control plane
remains available during cluster
maintenance like rotating IPS upgrading
control plane VMS or resizing clusters
or node pools
when upgrading a regional cluster two
out of three control plane VMS are
always running during the rolling
upgrade so the kubernetes API is still
available
similarly a single zone outage won't
cause any downtime in the regional
control plane
backup for gke is a fully managed
service that helps you protect manage
and restore your kubernetes workloads
and data in a simple scalable and secure
way
let's hear what one of our customers is
saying about backup for gke
Jose Chavez SAS platform and delivery
engineer at broadcom says backup for gke
makes it easier for us to protect our
stateful workloads in gke and it makes
restoring those stateful workloads much
simpler and faster
we see integrated backup as another sign
of gke's maturity for stateful workloads
and we look forward to using it to serve
our worldwide internal customers at
broadcom
backup for gke is a simple way to
protect manage and restore your
containerized applications and data
with backup for gke you can meet your
service level objectives and automate
common backup and Recovery tasks
you can protect kubernetes resources
such as namespaced resources
cluster-wide resources and persistent
volumes application data including
databases file systems and logs you can
seamlessly restore your backups to a new
or existing kubernetes cluster backup
for gke is configurable flexible and
easier to adopt for Enterprises
backup options allow you to select
preferred backup destinations or select
and Skip certain resources you can
configure backup not to include secrets
so the data is not visible via
persistent disk control plane
by enabling time lock backups you can
disable manual or automated deletion of
backups to protect from malicious
attacks
all data is encrypted by default with
the option of using customer managed
encryption Keys CMAC
the restore options let you restore a
cluster into a new cluster or a region
and flexibility of parameterizing the
restore options to different storage
classes
the subscope feature lets you restore a
specific namespace or application if
it's accidentally deleted or an upgrade
fails by delegating an admin cluster
admins can give access to app admins to
do ad hoc backups before critical
application upgrades
this diagram shows the relationship
between the different components for
backup in gke
the resource-based rest API based
service serves as the control plane for
backup for gke and includes Google Cloud
console UI elements that interact with
the API
the agent runs in every cluster where
backups or restores are performed and
performs backup and restore operations
by interacting with the backup for gke
API
let's demonstrate how you can enable
backup for gke through the gcp console
in the Google Cloud console navigate to
Google kubernetes engine and click
backup if this is the first time you are
creating a backup enable the backup for
gke API
click enable backup next to the cluster
that requires backup and restore
add required details to create plan for
the backup
now you're all set for more resilient
gke workloads on Google Cloud
we hope you found this video helpful
check out the links in the description
to learn more about backups for gke and
to try some Hands-On Labs thanks for
watching